wer bei shampoo
jede seite
er weiß schon heute morgen sind wir
morgen wieder des neubeginns
serviceleute wir sind nicht in new york
wir sind in der bavaria filmstadt und
hier wurden einige sehr berühmte filme
gedreht wir zeigen euch einen blick
hinter die kulissen
das ist dpa hallo bier
sie führt uns ein bisschen rum auf dem
gelände hier
die lage merklich ist ganz schön wenig
filme kennt zum beispiel hier
diese kulisse kenne ich nicht und schon
sehr aufwendig gemacht
wenn hier raus schaut auf der rechten
seite das ist eben die ehemalige
außenkulisse der serie marienhof man hat
hier einen strand zug aus köln
nachgebaut und das ganze aus holz ganz
großartig auf der linken seite ist auch
die drittgrößte halle die wir haben da
wurde zum beispiel das boot gedreht was
nicht kopf das ist echt eng hier ist das
original größer als echtes was
allerdings etwas breiter geh schon mal
zehn prozent genau dann wenn die drin
überhaupt drehen konnte weil es so eng
war ein echt ist es noch ein bisschen
enger und zwar in 48 männer gleichzeitig
hier drin muss man sich immer vor augen
halten und tonnen mehr um eine gut dass
wir da einfach wieder rausgehen können
gleich einzuschlafen
kuschelig halt ne also hier ist alles
sehr eng und klein
für mich wäre das nichts
wir müssen wir durch das der
maschinenraum und hier drin haben die
darsteller zehn monate lang drehen
müssen
geil
wir sind beim fuhr natürlich aus der
unendlichen geschichte der glückskette
das ist tatsächlich ein echter
glückskäfer aus dem ersten teil
da sieht man wie das mit der leinwand
funktioniert mit dem blue screen
das blau wird einfach nur ausgefüllt hat
genauso funktioniert beim wetter
herzlich willkommen
sie sehen wird es sehr bewölkt im süden
deutschlands haben konnte wisse die
sonne durch die leute die in köln wohnen
sollten vielleicht doch bleiben und
nicht nach berlin fahren tschüss das
war's müssen am ende angekommen
hier wird alles gezeigt kommt auf meine
vielen dank wir hatten sehr viel spaß
bis zum nächsten mal